من النار اللهم اجر من النار اللهم اجر من
النار اللهم اجر من النار اللهم اجر من
الله
بسم الله الرحمن الرحيم الحمد لله والصلاه
والسلام على رسول الله
اما بعد يقول الحافظ النووي رحمه الله
تعالى في رياضه في باب الاخلاص واحضار
النيه في جميع الاعمال والاقوال والاحوال
البارزه والخفيه
قال وعن ابي هريره
رضي الله عنه قال قال رسول الله صلى الله
عليه وسلم ابو هريره نيم وات يا اخوه
عبد الرحمن بن صخر الدوسي
وين
the battle of
passed away
we keep mentioning this
brother said
قال رسول الله صلى الله عليه وسلم صلاه
الرجل في جماعه تزيد على صلاته في سوق
وبيتي بضع و درجه
جماعه
place
‏mar
[Silence]
‏narration that it doesn't mean there
noays
of the general in the propet
say
that a man's prayer along with another
is better than his prayer alone
and two men's prayer along with a third
is better than their prayer alone so
there's always more virtue the
[Silence]
وذلك ان احدهم وذلك وذلك هو يشرح هنا هذا
تفسير ما اجمله
في الجمله السابقه فهو يقول قولا ثم يقول
وذلك فهذه الجمله تفسيريه
وذلك ان احدهم اذا توضا فاحسن الوضوء احسن
يعني اتقن الوضوء
وضوء
وضوء ثم اتى المسجد لا يريد الا
لا ينهزه الا الصلاه ينهزه يعني يحركه
وينهضه
لم يخطو خطوه الا رفع له بها درجه
وحط عنه بها خطيئه
حتى يدخل المسجد
فاذا دخل المسجد
كان في الصلاه ما كانت الصلاه هي تحبسه
‏entay
والملائكه
يصلون على احدكم والملائكه
جمع ملك
جمع مالك
واصل هذه الكلمه من الالوكه
والالوك هي الرساله
والمالك
هو المرسل برساله
عظيمه
فالملائكه
هذه هذا جمع ل
المرسلين
لان اشرف
ما تعمله الملائكه
اداء رسائل الله سبحانه وتعالى
والملائكه
جمع ونؤمن بما جاء عن الملائكه عاما وخاصا
خاصا يعني بجميع ما توصلنا اليه عن طريق
الكتاب والسنه من علم عن الملائكه
واحوالهم واسمائهم
و شرفهم
ودرجاتهم
واعمالهم ووظائفهم
ونؤمن عاما بجميع ما لم نعلمه عنهم وهو
ثابت
فهذا الايمان ايمان عام وايمان خاص
فالملائكه
من اركان الايمان
الايمان بالملائكه
كما جاء عن النبي صلى الله عليه وسلم هنا
يصف النبي صلى الله عليه وسلم لنا
نوعا من الملائكه
يشغلهم الدعاء لبني ادم
و
هم مامورون من قبل الله سبحانه وتعالى
بورود
بيوت الله ومساجد الله لحضور
مجالس الذكر والصلوات والخطب وقراءه
القران وما شابه ذلك
وثم ادله تدل على ان الملائكه
تحضر المسجد فتصلي وتستمع الى الخطب
وتحيط بمن ذكر الله يقول النبي صلى الله
عليه وسلم وما اجتمع قوم في بيت من بيوت
الله يتلون كتاب الله ويتدارسونه
فيما بينهم الا غشيتهم الرحمه ونزلت عليهم
السكينه وحفتهم الملائكه حفتهم يعني
احاطوا بهم
وذكرهم الله في من عنده اسال الله تعالى
لنا اجمعين هذا الاجر من الله واسال الله
تعالى ان يذكرني واياكم في من عنده سبحانه
و الملائكه
صلى الله عليه وسلم والملائكه يصلون على
احدكم ما دام في مجلسه الذي صلى فيه
الصلاه
me here will prop صلى الله عليه وسلم
what
ang
make up each of you as
in place that he prayed
ملائكه
الالوك
مالك ملك
الملائكه
‏here by
me by pray herean
ang pray upon each of you as he in the
place
and we see here the angels
are types of angels that are commion
الله سبحانه وتعالى
اللهعا
[Silence]
‏as
place.
‏So here we see that the angels
are with us in the are in the houses of
Allah
and brings about
the
صحيح
ان الملائكه
لتذى
مما يتاذى منه ابن ادم
ofising
person
of being smelly foul stenches foul odors
‏Don't
bring sym into
make that will disple in own house this
kind of things all have to do with the
angels.
ان شاء الله تعالى نسال الله تعالى بمنه
وكرمه وجوده ان يبارك لي ولكم في القران
العظيم اساله تعالى ان ينفعني واياكم بما
فيه من الايات والذكر الحكيم والله اعلم
وصلى الله وسلم على نبينا محمد وعلى اله
واصحابه اجمعين والحمد لله رب العالمين
جزاكم ‏No.